el primer terremoto registrado desde que
comenzó el siglo XXI fue el de India el
26 de enero de 2001 la tierra se sacudió
en un sismo de magnitud 7,9 y dejó un
reporte de 14.000 Muertos el número de
heridos 150.000 luego el 26 de diciembre
de 2003 bam en Irán se vio sacudido por
un terremoto de magnitud 6,6 31.000
personas murieron el 26 de diciembre de
2004 la provincia de asegen Indonesia
registró un terremoto de magnitud 9,15
que desató un tsunami en el océano
Índico considerado el más devastador de
la historia hubo 226.000 muertos dos
millones de personas quedaron sin hogar
en la provincia de chuan en China el
terremoto de magnitud 7,8 causó 70.000
muertes derribó escuelas fábricas y al
menos un hospital el 12 de enero de 2010
un terremoto de magnitud 7 sacudió Haití
el país más pobre de de América Latina
dejó un saldo de 250.000 Muertos 1,5
millones quedaron sin hogar un seísmo de
magnitud 9 mató unas 15.690 personas en
Japón otras 5.700 quedaron heridas el
terremoto desató en fukushima un
desastre considerado el segundo peor
tras la catástrofe nuclear de chernóbil
en 1986 el 25 de abril de 2015 nepal fue
sacudida por un temblor de 7,8 murieron
unas 9000 personas templos ciudades y
lugares históricos quedaron en ruinas
sulahuesia en Indonesia fue sacudida el
28 de septiembre de 2018 por un
terremoto y un posterior tsunami con
olas de 1,5 metros que dejaron más de
4.000 personas muertas